I'd say today's lecture is
about behavioral finance.
Um, and, uh,
this is a term that emerged into public
con consciousness around the mid 1990s.
Before that,
it was unknown.
The term efficient markets is much older.
I mentioned the idea,
it goes back to the 19th century.
The term goes back to the 1960s.
Uh,
but behavioral finance is a newer,
a revolution in finance.
Uh,
and it's something that I had
been very involved with. Um,
I have an organizing workshops in
behavioral finance ever since 1991 working
with a professor Richard Thaler
at University of Chicago.
So we've been doing that for
18 years. Amazing. That's a
long time for you, right?
Uh, when we started, we
were a total outcast.
We thought nobody appreciated us.
Uh,
I had tenure so I could
do it. But, uh, you know,
the problem is you don't want to do
things that are too out of fashion. Uh,
fortunately we have a system
that allows it to happen.
I'm very happy to have that. But, uh,
what behavioral finance is,
is a reaction against extreme,
some extreme,
uh,
that we see in efficient markets
theory or also in mathematical finance.
Mathematical finance is a beautiful
structure and I admire what they've people
have done and I've worked in it
myself. Um, but, uh, it has its limits.
And, uh, eventually, uh, you know,
the way of paradigm develops,
it goes through a certain phase.
When mathematical was finance was new,
say in the 1960s,
it was all the exciting thing and nobody
wanted to work on anything else you
wanted to be doing.
The exciting thing, uh,
as the 70s and eighties wore on,
it got to be a little bit over done.
You know,
people run with it too far and they think,
they think that's all we want to do and
we don't want to think about anything
else. And then they start to get
sometimes a little crazy. Uh, and uh,
and so then we had to
reflect that, well, you know,
things aren't perfect and the world isn't,
isn't perfect and we have real
people in the world. Uh, so, uh,
uh, that led to the behavioral finance.
So behavioral finance really means,
what does it mean? Uh, it's
not like behavioral psychology.
It doesn't mean behavioral
psychology applied to finance.
It really means something
much more broad than that.
It means all of the other social
sciences applied to finance. So,
uh, the, um, uh,
the economics department is just one of
many departments in the university that,
uh, uh, uh, teaches us something
about how people behave.
And so if we want to
understand how people behave,
we can't rely only on
economics department.
So I think that it's coming around to
a, a unifying of our understanding. Uh,
and, uh, since then, uh, since
the beginnings in the 90s,
I behavioral finance workshops have
grown and grown. And of course,
so many people are involved in it now.
It's now very well established.
So before I get into that,
I wanted to give some additional
reflections on the last lecture. Uh,
and I have this chart which
you saw last time. Uh,
actually it's an excel spreadsheet that I,
uh,
I also put it up already
on the, uh, on the,
um, classes vitu website
and so you can play with it.
Uh,
but I just wanted to reflect again.
I know I'm repeating myself a little bit,
but it's very important and I'll, uh,
uh,
what we have in this chart is the Blue
Line is the standard and poor come out of
the Stock Price Index.
Uh,
going back to 1871 from 1871,
two,
uh, 2008 right now. So that's a,
uh, like 130 years of data.
And that's the Blue Line.
You can see the,
you know what that is there.
That's 1929 and that,
that is the crash of 1929. Well,
actually it extended it to 1932.
Uh,
and you can see other historic movements.
There's the bull market of the 1990s.
Very big upswing.
And then here's the
crash from 2000 to 2003.
I don't know if you remember these things.
They were a big news,
not as big as the 1929 crash,
but the upswing was just as big
as the 1920s. Upswing, wasn't it?
Here's the 1920s upswing. And
here's that. In 1990s, upswing.
Huge upswing and stock prices.
Um,
this is enlarged by the way. So
that means that, uh, everything, uh,
uh, the same vertical distance, uh,
it refers to the same
percentage change in the price.
And then I had, as I said last year,
I have a random walk, uh, shown.
So that's the pink line
and the random walk is, um,
is generated by the
random number generator.
I fixed the random number generators,
so I made it truly normal this time
and it slows it down a little bit.
But if you press f nine,
we get another,
a random walk,
but it's always the same stock price.
Uh,
this is the random walk with a trend that
matches the uptrend of the stock price.
So, uh, I can press it.
So it kind of looks similar,
doesn't it?
It kind of shows that in some basic sense,
the stock market and the random
walk are, are, are the same.
Uh,
here we have the crash of [inaudible].
Here we have the market peak of 1929.
Right.
He said it turned out in this simulation
to have occurred in 1910 or thereabout.
And then we have the, uh, that's
the depression of the 30s,
except it's not the 30 days.
And I can just push a button and we get
something else. I find this amusing.
I don't know. Um, so, uh,
unfortunately we lived through only
one of these in our lifetime. Um,
there's a TV show about
parallel universes, right?
What's the name of that show?
I can't remember. It isn't
there. You don't, you know,
this show where they go in some kind
of a time machine and they emerge in
another parallel universe where history
took another course. Well, anyway,
these are parallel
universes that we're seeing
in some of these universes.
Jeremy Siegel would write his book stacks
with alarm run and in some of them he
wouldn't, not because, uh,
well this one he might not because in
this case the stock market was just
declining for the better
part of a century. Uh,
and, uh, the, the thing I
don't see in these charts,
and I think we haven't
captured it perfectly with
just the standard random walk
is I don't see any crash as big as the
29 crash. I mean, it's hard to get them.
I keep pushing f nine, uh,
this just seems to dominate,
right? There's nothing as big
here. Uh, press f nine. Again,
I mean, you can keep pushing and pushing
and maybe you'll get one, but you have,
you get the idea that there's something
anomalous about that crash from the
standpoint of this random walk
theory. I'm not getting one. Right?
Uh, and that's something we'll
talk about it I would attribute,
I'm not, I can push for a
long time and I don't see,
well there is a pretty big one.
Isn't that just about a shirt?
Not Quite as sharp as 19, uh, 19,
29 crash. But it's hard to get them. Uh,
so I think that one thing, there's a
couple of things that we'll come back to.
One is I think I've already mentioned it.
Fat Tails that uh,
stock price movements have a tendency to,
uh,
show some extreme outliers that are not
represented by the normal distribution.
But also, um, there's
variations in the variance.
So in this period here in
the twenties and thirties,
the stock market was extremely
variable on a day to day basis.
It was way beyond anything
we've observed since. Uh,
and so that's why it seems to be more
volatile in that period because cumulation
of bigger random shocks. So, uh,
anywhere we can play this
game for a while. But, uh,
now I wanted to then go and talk about,
remember that the,
the,
the random walk that we see in stock
price is not the behavior of a drunk,
even though you can describe a
random walk is drunk and behavior.
But the idea in the theory is that this,
these movements only appear random
because they're news and news is always
unpredictable as the market
is doing the best job.
This is efficient markets in
predicting the future. And so,
uh, that, uh, that means then that
anytime the stock market moves,
it's because something
surprising happened.
Like there might be a new
breakthrough in science or a,
there could be a war or something outside.
This is the story outside of the
economic system that disrupts thing. So,
uh, the next question then, and
now I've added something to it.
It's on this little tab here,
I've added something which is a,
a plot of present values.
And this is something that
I published in 1981. Well,
it's a long time ago,
isn't it?
It was my first big success.
Not everyone liked this article,
but what I, I got into a lot of
trouble for it. Uh, I learned, uh,
some people, uh, react to
hostility when you, uh,
offender cherished beliefs. So I was on
the outs for a while with this article,
but I said,
well,
it's kind of interesting to think that
all these apparently random movements are
really resulting in news about
something that is fundamental,
right?
That's the efficient markets every time
the stock market moves is because there
was some news about, about what, well,
it's about present value.
The efficient market theory
in its simplest incarnation
says that the price is
the expected present
value of future dividends.
So what I did in a paper that I
published in 1981, as I said, well,
let's just plot the present
value of dividends through time.
And that's how I constructed this long
time series back to 1871 nobody else was
looking at it. Uh, you know,
typically researchers want the best data,
the high quality data.
And so they would look at recent data,
which is the best data and they would
think going back to 1871 is is crazy
because that's so long ago and we have
daily or minute by minute data by now we
can't get it for that remote period.
But on the other hand, as I argued,
the stock market is pricing things
that occur over long periods of time.
The present value formula is
pricing dividends into the future,
decades into the future?
Well actually to the infinite future,
but most of the weight is
on the next few decades.
So we can't evaluate the theory, right?
Just looking at 10 years of data,
we've got to get a lot of data.
So what I did then and that paper is
I computed the actual present value of
subsequent dividends or each year and
that's on this tab and compared it with
the stock price. Okay.
So that's what I did.
This is an update of an arm of the
plot that I showed in my 1981 American
economic review paper. So the Blue
Line, because when I published it,
I was right here. It's amazing
how time goes by, right?
1979 I was right here.
We had just come off from a big
stock market dropped, but the um,
the, well it was the 70, uh,
73 75 drop and it was a
couple of years later.
So we were kind of
bumbling around down here.
We didn't have any idea whether
this was coming at that time, but,
so what I did is I just for each year
I computed the present value of the
dividend. I have a dividend series
for every year. In fact, it's,
it's right over here. Um, I have two, uh,
this is the data. So, um,
I have the, this is the s and p
price index monthly back to 1871.
And here's the dividends they paid
per share every year since 1871.
So I just, for each year I took
all subsequent dividends and I, um,
I um, price them out at uh, uh,
uh, the present value formula. And I use
a constant discount rate of 6% a year.
Uh, and so you see how we get
what the present value was.
I of course there's a problem is we
don't know dividends at the after 2007,
because we don't have data
on dividends pass them,
but I just made some assumption.
So the value at the end is
maybe a little bit arbitrary.
It could be dragged up or down if I made
a different assumption about dividends
at the end,
but more or less,
this is going to be what actually the
present value of dividends was over this
whole period.
And so,
so here's the dilemma and this
is what I said in 1981 article.
This is the thing that is
supposed to be forecasted, right?
That's the present value. And the Blue
Line is the forecast of that thing.
So then you ask,
does this look like a good forecast where
people doing a good job of forecasting
the red line with the Blue Line?
Uh,
now that may be a loaded
question. How about, uh,
I think that you get the impression that
there's something possibly wrong here
with efficient markets because the red
line is just a smooth growth path and
like nothing happens to it.
Uh,
and yet the stock market is going
up and down all over the place. Uh,
sorry. It's a little bit
like a, if you had a weather
forecaster. Alright. And, uh,
this morning he says,
I predict today that the low
today will be minus 100 degrees.
Okay.
And then two days later he said,
I predict that the load today
will be plus 150 degrees. Uh,
you would eventually start concluding
that this weather forecast or can't be
trusted because we never
get to those temperatures.
And that's sort of what the
stock market is doing. It's,
it's fluctuating much more than a thing
that's forecasted unless you gotta be
careful.
I ended up with so many critics,
there's a lot of issues here
that, uh, some people said, well,
but of course people don't know where
the red line was last period. Uh,
and other people said,
well,
you just are showing one reality
for the realization you're showing.
They kind of get back to
this parallel universe story.
There must be another universe where
there's another earth and where everything
looks the same except that the red line
did something very different. Okay.
And that could be, so people
are saying, you never know.
There could have been a communist
revolution in America, uh,
in the 1930s and they
could have nationalized the
whole stock market and then
the red line would be down at zero. Right.
They would have taken the whole thing,
uh, or there could've been
some good news, I dunno,
some great breakthrough that
we haven't discovered yet, but,
and another reality they could have.
And so all this noise in the stock
market could have somehow been new
information about things
that didn't happen. Um,
and so, uh, well,
I mean I think we're getting kind of
philosophical when we'd go to that.
The point is that we've never seen
any movement in the present value of
dividends that would justify the movement.
And if we knew the future with
certainty according to this model,
then the stock market would behave like
the red line, not like the Blue Line.
So, um, uh,
well, anyway, I, for example,
let's look at the Great Depression of
the 1930 [inaudible] at least at the very
least,
I think this chart will show a reveal
some misconceptions that some people have.
The Great Depression of the
1930s was awful, right? I
mean, you hear these stories,
I assume you hear these stories.
We had 25% unemployment at the peak.
Uh, right. It sounds really bad. You
had people selling apples on the street.
You must know these images,
right? So it sounds awful.
But look what happened to Pete
Starr in the Great Depression.
I can't hardly see anything,
but what actually happened was businesses
continued paying their dividends right
through the whole depression and
some of them cut their dividends.
Uh, but it was only for
a few years, you know,
and so the present value of the value of
stock depends on what it pays out over
decades, not just next year. So the
stock market, if people knew the,
that even if they knew
the depression was coming,
they shouldn't have marked down
in the stock market so much, uh,
according to the simple efficient market
story according to the present value
story. So I, you know, it's very least,
I think that this diagram helps
you to see what, uh, what is,
what is wrong or what
simple theories are wrong.
And so it must be that if the stock
market is reacting to new information
overall,
this century of history,
it must have been new information about
things that just didn't happen. You know,
it could be that an asteroid almost
struck the earth and then it just missed.
And so, uh, the stock market
crashed and then when it missed,
it came back up again. Right. And so we
don't see any interruption in dividends,
but it has to be something
like that, uh, that, uh,
that the, the problem has. I
can't think of anything like that.
I don't think that any asteroid
came close to the earth,
not fast enough to be worried about.
And I can't think that the communist
revolution had much chance of taking place
in the United States. So, uh, but you
can imagine. And so we don't know, uh,
behavioral finance kind of tends to
reach the opposite conclusion that this
volatility in the stock market
is the sign of something else.
It's some social forces,
some speculative bubbles,
some activity that is not
related to anything fundamental.
And so the reason that I got so much
hostility when I wrote these papers is I
was,
I was striking a nerve,
I guess because many people have developed
these beautiful mathematical theories
that said that the stock market was
the optimal predictor of everything.
And I was, uh, saying the
emperor has no clothes.
So there are others like the,
um, so what is happening?
You know what, I'm coming around to
think, maybe it's my cynical view.
I've always been a cynic.
I don't know if you are cynics are now,
I think people convince
themselves of things. They, they,
people think they understand things
better than they are. And so, you know,
you spend your whole life looking at
this one picture of the stock market and
you think you have an explanation
for all of it, all rational and good,
but you know, it's just overconfidence
that's doing that. It's an illusion. Uh,
so I wanted to talk about
over confidence. Uh, and uh,
I thought I'd try others. There's
also no eraser. I forgot to ask.
Uh, somebody is stealing things here. Um,
uh, can you find any racer for
meanwhile I can switch blackboards.
There's a little trick here.
It was probably just in this closet
or something. No, it's a lot.
Uh,
so I wanted to try an experiment of
asking you a series of a few short
questions, uh, and uh,
it's a game we'll play,
which I'll need your
cooperation with. Uh, so, uh,
these are questions about over confidence.
Actually,
I just want you to,
I want you to try to give me
a 90% confidence intervals
for the answers to these
questions. Um, do you know what a
90% confidence interval? It's, uh,
it's, uh, for example,
if I were to ask you, uh,
uh, what, um, how, how many,
how many people are there,
uh, in new haven? And, uh,
I want you to not just give me a number,
I want you to give me a range such
that you're 90% sure that you're right.
All right? So I could say, well,
it's between a 90,000 and 100,000
people and I'm 90% sure I'm right.
So if you give me a true
90% confidence interval,
then you should be right 90% of the time,
right?
So what I'm going to do is
give you a few questions and,
and ask you for a [inaudible]
ask you to write down,
you have a piece of paper there
and 90% confidence interval. Okay?
And I have five questions. This
is just an experiment. All right?
Uh, the first one is about
the statue of Liberty.
Okay.
What does it weigh in?
Pounds. Okay. No, and in tons.
Okay. So I'm good. Thank you. Uh,
so wait,
uh, incident, just to remind you a
ton is a u s town is 2000 pounds,
not a British tonne, which
is 2000, 240 pounds. Uh,
and a ton is 907 kilograms.
Okay.
So what can you write down on your paper?
Your 90% confidence interval?
Alright, so for example,
I won't use realistic numbers
if you thought it was,
you might write down it's between
one pound and three pounds. Okay.
And that you're 90% sure it falls
in that interval. Um, and um,
I didn't say it. It's tons. Tons. I'm
asking you. It's more than a pound.
I'll give you a hint. It's
in tons. And I want, now,
we also said we're not weighing the base.
The Statue of Liberty stands on a tall,
um, on a tall edifice.
We're not counting that,
but we're counting also the
steel reinforcing that they
put in. A few years ago,
you remember the statue of Liberty was
getting weak and they were worried that
something might topple down. So
they, they reinforced it on you.
We're counting that. So it's a
copper structure with um, uh,
steel reinforcement.
So can you write down on your notes
a range within which you're 90% sure.
Uh, that the statue ways. Okay.
In tons.
All right. If you could do that
and I'm going to come back,
what am I going to do is come back
and see how often you were right.
So we'll go back through this.
Have you all written down?
I wait for the Statue of Liberty.
Uh, okay. Population of the country.
Turkey.
Uh, but since I don't have
the current population,
I want it in the year 2000.
I didn't get the current latest estimate.
So how many people were there in Turkey?
In 2000.
Okay. And again, put down
a range. A low and a high.
90% sure.
MMM.
Sarah is Sahara desert.
How many square miles
in the Sahara desert? Okay. Uh,
and I remember that a square
mile is 2.6 square kilometer.
It was just in case you
think in terms of kilometers.
So you can devise your answer in
kilometers and then multiply by 2.6.
Um, you can write down a range. Okay.
Uh, enrollment. Yeah.
By the way, I should have asked, you
didn't have to be honest with it.
You could gain me by,
by writing really wide intervals for,
uh,
nine of the 10 questions and then an
extremely narrow interval for the 10th and
I'm expecting some sincerely
sincere cooperation here.
Then you would guarantee that you are
right. Exactly. 90% of the time. Right.
So I mean, you could say the Statue of
Liberty weighs between zero and a hundred
quintillion tons and you
know, you're right. Right.
And then you could deliberately say the
population of Turkey is one between one
and two people and then you know,
you're wrong and you could do it.
You're not supposed to do that. Okay. Uh,
so then I want the enrollment in Yale
and I don't have the latest number.
2005.
Okay.
That's the total number of students
at Yale University in 2005,
including Yale College. And
all the graduate schools. Okay.
Uh, and then the sixth, fifth question,
it's about the Pulitzer Prize.
You know this prize,
it's a prize that journalist win
for writing great articles or books.
I want to know what is that?
How much do you get in cash if you
win the Pulitzer Prize? All right.
And I have it for last year,
2007 it might be different in 2008.
So I'm asking for the 2007 in dollars,
okay. In dollars. Okay.
I hope you were feeling confidence
intervals if you've gotten them.
Now what I'm going to do, uh, and if
you've answered all five questions,
I'm going to tell you the answers,
the correct answer and then ask
for a show of hands of how many,
if you please be honest
and don't be embarrassed.
Raise your hand if uh,
if you were right men.
Meaning that if my answer falls
within your 90% confidence interval,
okay? So, okay, let's go
to the Statue of Liberty.
The Statue of Liberty weighs 252 tons.
Okay.
So can I have a show of hands?
How many people here had
it has 252 in the interval.
Okay. Okay. You're doing fairly well.
What fraction? Keep your hands up.
It looks like it's about,
uh, what, what would you say?
Like 20% and 25 so I thank you for
being honest and not gaming me.
It should have been 90%
right? Who were right. Okay.
What does the 2000 population of Turkey,
uh,
I'll give you the exact number, uh,
that I got from their statistic.
65 million.
666,677.
Okay,
so that's a little over 65 million.
So how many people have that
in their interval? Okay,
that's better. It's like 40%.
50, 40 or 50. You're doing,
you're doing better,
but it's still not 90.
How many square miles in the
Sahara desert? 3.5 million.
Okay. Can I get a show of hands?
How many were right on that? Well,
this one really got you.
There was like 5% right then.
You right on all of them so far.
Um,
enrollment in Yale fall 2005,
11,483 students. Okay.
How many were right? Uh,
okay, that's about a 40. It might
cost to fit 40, 40%. I said,
and finally, how much do you win? If you,
how much do you receive if you
win the Pulitzer Prize? $10,000.
Can I have a show of hands? That
was it. Okay. That was really low.
That's like 5%. I knew that was a trick.
If you've heard about the Nobel prize,
because those are both prestigious,
right?
Nobel prize gives you something on the
order of $1 million and the pilots are
prize gives you something like you only
gives you $10,000. How can that be? Uh,
so I sort of picked something
that I thought you might be wrong.
This is what that reveal something
about human behavior. You know,
it's a choice in life.
You go into different walks of life.
This is something that is
fundamental to economic.
There's just different expectations
of how much money you're gonna make.
And if you go into the news media,
and I think that's a wonderful career,
but you're not going to
make much money profitably.
And the whole thing is just scaled
down. Uh, and I think this, uh,
there's something revealing about this
that we just have social norms for how
much someone is to be paid.
So if you were to give Stephen
Schwarzman at $10,000 prize,
it would be more like an
insult or anything. Uh,
but if you are working for the new haven
register and you get this prize, it's,
it's a life changing event,
not because of the 10,000.
Maybe even they get more money than that.
But anyway,
the point was that, uh, people tend to
be overconfident. Uh, and incidentally,
it's not just males. Females are
well known to be overconfident too.
So there is this thing about macho males,
Norco,
but experiments prove that women
have the same problem. And so,
um, so that's why I think that when
we look at charts of the stock market,
we see things that we think we understand,
especially young people.
They get diluted into thinking. They
understand, uh, more than they really do.
So, uh, I wanted to talk about,
um, uh, some authors that, uh,
uh,
I admire who
written about this. Um, and, uh,
these are books that I don't have on the
reading list, but they're fun to read
is a professor at the Harvard
Business School of rock, cash corona.
Uh, he has a book, uh,
on a search for charismatic CEOs.
That is companies, uh, it's not
just overconfidence in your cell.
We tend to also to put overconfidence
in leaders. And so we have the,
uh, this is an a at the end we have a
sense that some people are just natural
geniuses and know everything.
And so we, we, we, we, uh,
we think that they can transform
our lives or our companies.
And so our boards of directors
are constantly looking
for a CEO who is a genius
and it keeps getting fooled and this
disappointed they bring some money.
And this person often messes things
up more than helps because this person
realizes he or she has to
live up to this genius role.
So they better do something.
So they do something in a flailing way,
not understanding what they're doing and
they mess up the whole company. Really.
A lot of what happens in good things that
happen in human society are the result
of lots of people doing their own
special things and all working together.
And there's no great genius a underneath.
But there's this idea in our
mind that one, we are, uh,
we're going to be such a thing. Um, um,
related to that I want to dimension
and it's on the reading list. Um,
and article by, um,
one of my students, uh,
in this class who is now at Mit,
he took this class,
uh,
about 10 years ago.
How far the cannon, uh, and
coauthor with another MIT professor,
uh, gender, uh, and the
guests looking at, uh,
over confidence in our judgements.
Again, they look at Ceos,
chief executive officers of
companies, and they found that, um,
companies, uh, the,
in industries that fail tend
to fire their CEOs. This is an,
this is unjust.
This is an overreaction.
You bring in a CEO who was
supposed to be brilliant, okay.
And then the business fails. So you
fire the guy right after that. So it,
you know, we're kind of manic
depressive about these guys when,
when the business fails,
we think we were such a mistake.
This guy had such promise and it just
didn't live up so we get rid of them.
But in fact they found that the CEO gets
fired even if the whole industry went
down. So I mean, you can't blame
the CEO for the fact, you know,
if you're one company in an industry and
the whole industry goes down, uh, or the,
the remaining industry even not including
that for, it's not the CEOs fault.
So we tend to be kind of wild
and extreme in our judgments.
You've seen that a lot.
A lot of CEOs lost their jobs
recently in the subprime crisis. Uh,
was it their fault? Probably not.
You know, but they get fired anyway.
Uh, so we go through this
manic depressive, uh,
we try to hire charismatic CEOs,
then we get disappointed and we
keep going through musical chairs,
a one after another. Um, and then, uh,
Nassim Taleb,
uh,
lives here in Connecticut
and I know him well.
He has a book called fooled by randomness,
which was a best seller.
Uh, and it's very fun
to read. It's a story.
He's a Wall Street. He had a, um,
an investment management firm, uh,
and he observed a lot of people,
and it's a book about how
people, uh, over interpreted,
they tend to blame themselves for
failures and congratulate themselves for
success is too much. And they don't
realize that it's just random.
So some guy who's in a business,
what the business is succeeding,
why is it succeeding?
Because the guy came in dumb luck
at the right time and everything is,
is supporting. That concludes
that he's a genius. Uh,
and then, uh, Taleb observes
them later after, after, uh,
things don't go so well and then suddenly
they're, uh, they are depressed. And,
uh, uh, you know, I talked to, uh,
a stockbroker's before and after the 87
stock market crash and one of them told
me,
or maybe more than one of them told me,
I can tell that the crash occurred from
the tone of Voice of the people when
they call up the phone.
So when the market was soaring
just before the 87 peak,
he said they would call up and
they were brash and rude to me,
and they would say, let's
trade this, get this done.
Kind of a dis disparaging slit.
Suddenly the, uh, the stockbroker,
and then after the crash,
when these people were sort
of, many of them wiped out,
they'd answered the
phone in a sheepish way.
You can just tell in the tone of
their voice that they were crushed.
And so that's what happens.
I also have down on the, um,
on this part of the reading
list, Irving Fisher, uh,
who was a professor at Yale, uh, who, uh,
was a very prominent economist
in the first half of the century.
He, another year I'll graduate.
Yeah. A class of 1895. I think he,
I'm sure he lectured on this stage because
this building was with his office was
in this building, I believe.
Uh, he died around mid 1940s,
but he's famous for overconfidence,
uh,
in 1929,
he was interviewed just before,
two weeks before the 1929 peak.
And do you know what I'm referring to?
Uh, he said he thought the stock market
was on a permanently high plateau.
Uh, and he wrote a book
in 1929. I actually,
it came out in 1930 about the,
with this extremely optimistic
outlook for the market. Uh, and,
uh, he had a beautiful mansion.
He was a wealthy man for a while,
but he lost everything in the stock
market crash. In fact, he had this,
he had borrowed against his
home and he lost his house. Uh,
and so Yale University bought his
house for him and rented it out to him,
otherwise he would be on the
street. Um, so, uh, so I have him,
I have an article written by him
in 19, uh, 30, I think it's 1930,
or at the end of 29 discussing
the stock market trash.
And he still is unrepentant and this
was our most brilliant professor here at
Yale, but he just totally
misjudged the market. Uh,
so he's just totally unrepentant.
He just went back over his book.
There's so many good reasons.
the 20s where a spectacular era.
It's so many good reasons to stock
market will keep going up and he just
wouldn't back down.
In fact,
what he actually did is he started
borrowing from his relatives.
He had wealthy relatives
and he lost all of it. Um,
you just couldn't have imagined
that the stock market would go down.
It was just no reason that he could
think of it as that's what he says in the
article. So anyway, um,
I wanted to talk more precisely
about, um, how people behave.
This is all general about overconfidence,
but there are some other factors that,
uh, I want to, uh,
start with and that the most,
the most important theory in
behavioral finance is the,
um,
Kahneman and Tversky prospect theory.
So Danny Conoman,
who is now I professor of psychology
at Princeton and Amos Tversky,
uh, who, uh, is a died a few years ago.
They wrote the, I think the
most famous article on, um,
uh, on behavioral economics.
Uh, it goes beyond just finance.
Uh, and the title of the
article was prospect theory.
Okay. And that was 1979. Uh,
this is, I think the most,
actually I think there is a
ranking of economics articles,
scholarly articles by
numbers of quotations.
And this was number two out of all
articles written in the last 50 years. Um,
number one, I was quoted
for some other reason. I,
I'm not sure it was some statistical
method that everyone quoted,
but in terms of an
intellectual contribution,
this is the most important economics
article in the last 50 years,
at least judge by how
many times it's cited. Uh,
and so common and diversity are not
really talking about overconfidence,
but something about perhaps related to it,
something more general.
It's how people make choices.
And there's two elements to this theory.
It's a re it replaces expected utility.
Okay.
Uh, and it, uh, it has, uh,
when it does that replaces the
utility function with a value function
with value function and it
replaces the probabilities
with what they call wait.
So I'm going to explain what that
is and we'll move on. But, um,
let me give it a little story
that leads up to it. Uh,
and it's the story that Paul Samuelson
is a professor at Mit to all Paul
Samuelson, uh, highly esteemed ps.
I think he's 92 or 90,
about 92 years old now and still
writing, still working. Uh,
he was a math, he is a mathematical
economist, retired now,
but he told the story that illustrates
some of the beginnings of prospect.
In fact,
he kind of anticipated prospect theory.
This goes back to an article
that he wrote, uh, in 1963.
So, uh, in 1963,
he was having lunch with one of
his colleagues, another economist.
He doesn't name this other person
because it would be embarrassing,
but everyone knows it.
Was He Carrie brown professor at Mit.
And so Samuelson, uh, in a playful mood,
he was orange was sort of a playful
person. He said, I'm at lunch.
He said, hey, let's toss a coin. Let's
make a bet just for the fun of it. Okay.
And if it comes up, heads are
give you $200, but if it comes up,
tails you give me $100. And he
said, let's do it. I'm ready.
Okay. And this can I took
he Carrie brown by surprise.
That's that. That sounds like a lot
of mine. Especially in 1963. Right?
The prices were much
lower. That's like, uh, uh,
what was like $1,000 in 2000 something.
It was big money,
but of course these professors could
afford it. Uh, it's not that much money.
So let's just say it's 102 hundred.
Right. Do you feel like taking,
if I were to offer that to you right now,
let's do it because you
don't have cash on you now,
but you'd have to promise to pay
me if it came out wrong. All right.
Do you feel like doing that? If someone
is telling you, answering me honestly,
uh, interest back and think
about it. Well, this is suddenly
thrust on you. Um, yeah.
So Eat Carrie Brown said, oh, come on. I
don't, you know, I don't want to do this.
Sanderson was being annoying,
right?
Then Samuelson thought it had another
idea. He said, what if I offered,
he didn't actually offer this.
What if I offered to,
let's do this a hundred times.
We'll toss a coin a hundred times
and each time it comes up heads,
I give you $200 and each time it comes
up, tails you give me a $100 well, he,
Carrie Brown, knowing mathematics of
statistics and the law of probabilities,
he said, well, if we do it a hundred
times by the binomial Theorem,
I'm sure to when I couldn't pass it,
this is the elementary a hundred times.
A lot of times, in fact, I'll make
thousands of dollars. And so he,
Carrie von said, I'll do it. I would
do it. They didn't actually do it.
And Samuelson then said he went back to
his office and he wrote a paper that's
this 1963 paper proving that
he carry wrong was irrational.
You cannot possibly say,
I will take a hundred of them,
but I won't take one of them.
That's not rational. Uh,
and so that was one of the motivating
things in Kahneman and Tversky.
So what kind of an intro,
first Persky said is that people behave.
If you could introspect and imagine why
some of you didn't feel like taking this.
Beth people behave as if they,
they have a kink in their,
this may sound abstract way of putting it,
but I expected utility theory.
Uh,
the traditional theory says that everybody
has a utility function that
they consistently refer to
when making calculations.
So I'm going to put the
condom and diversity over
here and I'm going to put, um,
expected utility theory over here.
And so expected utility theory
says that I want wealth.
I called w wealth and I
get utility from wealth.
That's you and my utility curve.
And it has maybe any number of shapes,
but it's concave downward and smooth.
So you have what's called
diminishing marginal utility.
That's expected utility theory.
So what expected utility theory means
that the slope is always decreased.
Every extra dollar a wealth gives
me less happiness. Uh, but it's,
it always gives me a little bit more.
So I always want more,
but expected utility theory would
say that that's a two for one. Beth,
let's say Amazon is offering, uh, and
it's small compared to my lifetime. Well,
so my utilities essentially linear over
the relevant range plus or minus plus
200 and minus 100. And so, um,
and so I don't, uh, I don't
really concern myself about risk.
I should just take every bet
like that all the time. Uh,
and so you should always be looking,
if you, if you are behaving this way,
you should always be looking. Anyone
who works in make a bet with me anytime,
I'll always take it if
it's in my advantage even a
little bit in my advantage.
Um, now people seem to like to gamble,
but they don't like to do it consistently.
They like to go to the,
they ended up going to gambling casinos,
whether it's stacked against them, that
for them, but it somehow as a range,
as an infant, as a entertainment. Well,
Carmen and first he said that,
uh,
people don't behave this way and it's
as if they have a value function as a
function of their money. And, uh,
let's put in the middle of the
value from the reference point.
I can't write down that route.
Reference Point means where
you are today and your value,
that's V,
which is like utility,
but now we're talking in psychological
terms and so we give it a different name.
The value function has a,
uh,
a kink is something like
that at the reference point.
So, and then I'm trying to
draw it. It's not necessarily,
I have it mixed.
It looks here like two straight lines.
And that's not quite the way they do it.
Let me try and do this again. Um, it's,
it's curve downward a little bit,
but it becomes much less.
I don't want her, I'm having trouble
drawing this on the board. Well,
I don't want to ever
current keep wind down it.
If there's a kink here where the slope,
I think I've got it sort of there.
It's concave down everywhere.
It just like the utility function is,
but there's a discontinuity
of slope right here.
And where is that? That's where I
am now. And so what it means is,
is that I value loss as much more
than I value gains from wherever I am.
There's a big difference between
losing and winning. So when I,
when I reflect on this bed,
I'm thinking of I could lose $100,
and that scares me. It feels bad.
The idea that I would, I would,
I would just feel bad.
Um,
and so gaining $200 is positive for me,
but it doesn't offset the
loss that I might make.
So if I have equal
probabilities, uh, what,
what do you want to do is wait [inaudible]
the gains and losses and the losses
tend to dominate.
So you don't want to take the bet.
So the weighting function in incorporates
the Samuelson's lunch colleague
problem,
uh,
that people don't want to
take that to their advantage.
And it goes back to a kink in
the utility fund. Now incident,
this is fundamentally different
from in economic theory.
Economists would say, well, you can
put a kink in the utility function.
There could be some wealth level that
specialty you. But if theory economists,
that kink has to stay at a certain
wealth level with Carmen and diversity,
this kink moves around with you.
And so whatever, it's whatever,
you're always at the kink. So, uh,
because it's, it's not rational.
This is not rational expected
utility theory. This is,
I'm always looking at where I am now and
exaggerating in my mind the importance
of deviations from that. So people
are very concerned with small losses,
uh, and that that's what the
kink in the value function.
Now I want to talk to them about
another [inaudible] and diversity,
uh, saying the called
the waiting function. Uh,
so the weighting function,
uh,
it refers to the fact that people
distort probabilities in their mind.
And what
did
it,
it's not that they don't
know what probabilities,
but they distort them in their thinking.
So I'll give an example that illustrates
the continent risky waiting function
and it goes back years before
kind of an [inaudible]. Uh,
it's a famous example from
French economist Maurice La,
and it's called the La Paradox.
Uh,
and it illustrates,
uh,
thinking that violates expected
utility theory. So, uh,
I,
uh,
I'm going to give you a choice between
two prospects as kind of into risky call
them.
Suppose I offered you a 25% chance,
uh, to, to win
$3,000
or uh,
uh,
alternatively
a 20% chance
to win $4,000.
Okay.
Maybe I can get your show of hands.
All right. This is like saying listen,
lunch Kali again, but a little different.
I suppose I'm offering
and not offering this,
but suppose I have heard that you have a
choice between prospect one or prospect
to prospect one.
I'm going to toss a foresighted corn
and if it comes up with a probability of
one fourth in a certain way,
you will win $3,000 and prospect to,
uh,
I'm going to give you a
chance of 20% to win $4,000.
Can you tell me which of these you pick?
If you had to pick only one of these,
did you understand the question?
Okay.
How many would pick a number one?
Okay. It seems like it's about 20%.
How many would pick number two?
So most of you would pick number two.
Uh,
but then let's do a variation
on this question here.
It's a very simple variation.
Um, which would you prefer?
So this is one that you
picked most people pay. Okay.
Another prospect,
100% chance of winning
3000 or two uh,
that would be an 80% chance
of winning $4,000.
Okay. Did you see that? Okay.
If you pick prospect one,
you're going to just get $3,000 for sure.
If you big prospect to you,
you'll probably get 4,000 but at 80%
chance of it. How many would pick one?
Okay.
That looks like how many would pick two
or very few or even take two and every
so, so we take one this time. So now
you might want to reflect on that.
Why was it such a
different, uh, well, why,
why did you pick one in this
case and pick two in this case?
The thing I wanted to point out is that
the number that the cash amounts are the
same and the two examples, but the
probabilities are just multiplied by four,
right?
So the expected utility of the
two is just four times as great.
No matter what problem they were.
Yeah.
So they're the same. The utilities
are the same with the same numbers.
All I've done is multiply your
expected utility by four in this case.
So you can't make a different choice if
you pick too in over here when comparing
these two prospects,
you should also have picked two
when you compare these two prospect.
So why didn't you write
most of you switched? Uh,
can you tell me why?
Yes.
You would choose not to gamble.
Does this mean it's like a moral judgment?
Okay. You got it. Exactly. That's,
yeah. You got, you prefer certainty.
There's some anxiety about
maybe about, uh, about,
uh, you, you got it. Exactly right.
I think people like certainty,
uh, and, and ambiguity,
uh, is, uh, is difficult
for them to adjust to. So,
um,
but [inaudible] put it in this following
way that it's a little bit like we're
cavemen,
you know,
then it turns out we've all taught
to count and to do arithmetic,
but primitive people actually
have difficulty counting.
And there's an old story that cave had
only three numbers. One, two, and many.
Uh, I used to disbelieve this
story, but I've not actually,
it was a psychologist at Princeton told
me that as a matter of fact is proven
that there are some people whose languages
have only those numbers. One, two,
and many. Uh, and, uh, for example, the,
they're called in, um, Laos and Thailand.
There's a very primitive group of people
with primitive technology. I mean,
if they're primitive people, but
they only have one, two, and many.
And there's others have been discovered.
Uh, so emotionally were like that.
I used to wonder how could, how could
they have only those numbers? One, two,
and many. Like, could you ask her
mother, how many children do you have?
And she couldn't answer.
She didn't have a word three.
But it's a matter of fact they didn't.
And so I guess if you asked the
mother how many children you have,
she would probably just name them, right?
She couldn't say, I have three children.
Um, but anyway, we are all kind of like
that. When we think about probabilities,
that's condiment.
And so at carbon and diversity say that
we do is that in our minds we weight the
probabilities in a distorted way.
And this is the waiting function.
So we have the wait,
let's wait.
Not Wealth here against the probability.
I'm going to exaggerate a little bit.
This is zero and this is one whose
probabilities range from zero to one.
The whaling function looks like this,
I'm exaggerating a little
bit so you can see, but,
and then it jumps up or jumps down here.
This is the idea what kind of an first
he said in their original 79 article is
that we act as he goes.
There's a wide range of probabilities
here that are all kind of blurred and put
together. So, uh, we, we,
we minimize emotionally the
difference between probabilities.
They're all kind of in the middle.
So when I said 20 or 25,
in your mind you said,
here's 20 and here's 25.
But I don't think they're much different.
To me emotionally,
the money sounds different, but they've
set probabilities sounds the same.
So it's like I have only three
probabilities can't happen.
Might happen. And it's
certain to happen. Okay.
And so you tend to be pulled into these
certainty story that you give them much
more weight.
So the weight of what people do then and
summing up and expected utility theory.
In expected utility theory,
you maximize the probability
weighted sum of utilities
expected utility,
you maximize summation of
the probability of the,
I thought come times the
utility in the outcome.
But in prospect theory,
you maximize the, the,
some of the wait times the value function,
the values. Okay. And that's,
that's this is the condiment and risky,
a variation on expected utility theory.
So,
uh,
there's something related to it that
psychologist talk about how regret theory,
but it's, it's a little bit different,
but it's essentially the same as uh, uh,
it's consistent with a prospect theory.
Uh,
and that is that people are experienced
pain of regret and they do a lot of
things to try to avoid, uh, the
pain of regret. For example,
when the stock price stock
market goes up, uh, they, uh,
they tried to sell it and lock in the
game because they, they, they, they're,
they were worried that if it goes down
again, I will regret not having sold it.
And so that's not a rational calculation.
Uh,
if you come to some [inaudible]
coming to something that you,
you just have it and that escapes you,
you feel pain.
I guess that's what happened at
the Superbowl last night, right?
When the New England patriots had a
winning streak and they messed up at the
very end. That's exceptionally painful.
Uh, and that's part of regret theory.
I know how pain any of you are. Right?
It must've been painful to them. Anyway.
Uh, so, uh, um,
so I just mentioned some other things
that are related to prospect theory.
Uh, there's something
called mental compartments
that, uh, people, uh,
expected utility theory says your utility
depends on your whole lifetime wealth.
And so you should be always walked,
always thinking that everything happens
today is just part of a bigger story.
And I'm always thinking about my
lifetime and, and you know, I,
I had to do an exercise at the beginning
where I asked you to estimate the
present value of your lifetime income.
And it probably came out
to several million dollars.
And so if you were behaving rationally,
you would always be weighing
things against that big,
some of several million dollars.
That's why plus $100 plus minus 200,
who cares, right? That's the way
you should be thinking, right?
You don't think that way because
it's because you are human.
And so people put things
in mental compartments,
all different compartments in your mind
and you have separate values for thing
depending on which compartment
area. So for example, uh,
when you go to the gambling casino,
the winnings and losses
are completely different.
You just put them into a game
compartment and you think,
I can accept these and it doesn't matter.
Investors are that way too.
They sometimes put part of their
portfolio and I can play with this,
a mental compartment and others
in another mental compartment.
Um, so, uh, anyway, I just
wanted to come back and,
uh, I have, uh, maybe a little
bit more to say about this,
but let me come back
and talk just about the,
the problems that we talked about last
period. Um, problem set number three.
You've got your second problem set here.
Problem set number three is a
stock market forecasting exercise.
And the spreadsheet that I have up here
is one spreadsheet that you could use
to, uh, to do that. And
it's illustrated, I,
I clarified it a little bit
in the version I put up.
So you run a regression like that,
uh, to predict the stock market.
Uh,
and this is actually a hands on experience
that's supposed to help you eliminate
your overconfidence if I trying to
predict the market. Uh, but, um,
this is, uh, the example
where I tried to use time, uh,
as a predictor of the,
uh,
of the stock market and failed,
pretty decisively to do so. But
what I want to say is that, uh,
I have this spreadsheet up here which
has some data. It has monthly day.
This is my, um, hundred,
730 year long stock price series.
But you could add other
data, uh, and whatever.
If you can find data series somewhere,
it might be, it would be more fun, uh,
to try to predict, uh, using other data.
And so this is just for
you to really try to do it.
Some people do did sports things,
so if somebody wins the Superbowl,
maybe I don't know what the story is.
This is a famous story actually. Uh,
the stock market goes up or go, do you
know that? I don't know this exact,
a repeated store.
So you could create other variables
like a dummy variable for winning the,
somebody winning the Superbowl and
put that in. There's a famous story.
It goes back to the 1930s about skirt
lengths and the stock market. You know,
this story, uh, in the 1920s, uh,
an unprecedented thing
happened in women's fashion.
Never been seen before in a United States.
Women started wearing short
skirts and it was scandalous.
They weren't quite mini skirts,
but they were scandals and the women's
hemlines rose and peaked in 1929 and then
the skirt lengths came down in
the 30s right, with the market.
And so that was noticed and
some people thought, you know,
there was some euphoria that was
driving women crazy or something,
something about the twenties. The
optimism, the sense, uh, you know,
it sort of happened again in the 70s in
remember the miniskirts came in in the
70s. Right? And then the
70s, 74 crash didn't exactly,
I don't know if hemlines came down, but,
so anyway, I had one student who thought,
well, maybe there's other fashion
things that explained the market.
And she went back to microfilm newspapers
and measured the width of men's ties
in fashion advertisement. And she
thought, why ties are assigned,
it's like a short skirt, I guess it's
a sign of optimism and excitement.
And so she collected data on widths
of ties. She had a times here.
This was a very good answer.
Uh, great. Good problems.
And she collected 50 years of data on
the width of men's ties and correlate and
see if it predicted the market.
And unfortunately, it did not. Uh,
it was a wonderful tries.
I'm hoping that some of you can think
of interesting things to do, uh,
to try to predict the stock market.
All right,
so I'll see you again in two days.